antonio salió a correr cuatro días la
semana pasada corrió nueve kilómetros
cada día en esa misma semana blanca
corrió 15 kilómetros menos que antonio
cuantos kilómetros corrió blanca esta
semana vamos a hacer algo vamos a marcar
la información de antonio que sería
correr 4 días
y cada día corrió nueve kilómetros vamos
bien y blanca corrió 15 kilómetros menos
esto es importante son 15 kilómetros
menos que antonio si nosotros tenemos
cuatro días de antonio que corrió por
nueve kilómetros vamos a poder ver que
él corrió uno
dos días estoy sumando las distancias de
cada día un día corrió nueve kilómetros
otro día corrió nueve kilómetros
este es el tercer día que corrió 9 km
y este es el cuarto día que corrió 9 km
tenemos un total de distancia de antonio
en el que cada día corrió 9 km lo que
podemos hacer es simplemente sumar 9 + 9
18 927 más 9 36 podemos decir entonces
que 4 por 9 va a ser igual a 36
vamos a ponerlo por 9
va a ser igual
y estos son los 36 kilómetros que corrió
antonio durante estos 4 días de la
semana pero eso no es lo que nos están
preguntando nos está preguntando cuántos
kilómetros corrió blanca si nosotros
tomamos la distancia total digamos que
empezamos aquí
y toda la distancia que corrió antonio
es este camino hasta aquí todo esto
medirá 36 kilómetros estamos claros pero
nos dicen que blanca corrió 15
kilómetros menos así es que vamos a
pensar que más o menos blanca corrió
estos 15 kilómetros menos 15 kilómetros
menos nos regresamos porque ella no
terminó los 36 kilómetros corrió menos
entonces la distancia de blanca
realmente va a ser ésta
y estamos claros
vamos a ponerle aquí
distancia
y blanca
como vamos a saber cuánto es esta
distancia pues muy fácil podemos
pensarlo de dos maneras podemos decir
que la distancia de blanca vamos a
ponerle un ave para simplificarlo más
los 15 kilómetros que nos faltarían
correr
serán igual al total de la distancia
corrida de antonio es decir 36 km
o también lo podemos pensar de otra
manera podemos decir qué
la distancia que recorrió blanca va a
ser igual a los 36 kilómetros que corrió
antonio
- los 15 kilómetros que le faltaron
y de esta manera vamos a poder hacer la
solución de nuestro problema podemos
hacer simplemente aquí la resta en el
que tendremos que blanca
corrió 36 kilómetros menos 15 vamos a
hacer la resta 6 - 5 es igual a 1 y 3
menos uno es igual a 2 blanca corrió
entonces 21 kilómetros esa semana y esa
es nuestra respuesta correcta